welcome to the hugging face task series
in this video we'll take a look at the
question answering task
question answering is the task of
extracting an answer in a given document
question answering models taker context
which is the document you want to search
in
and the question and return an answer
note that answer is not generated but
extracted from the context
this type of question answering is
called extractive
the task is evaluated on two metrics
exact match and f1 score
as the name implies exact match looks
for an exact match between predicted
answer and the correct answer
a common metric used is the f1 score
which is calculated over tokens that are
predicted correctly and incorrectly it
is calculated over the average of two
metrics called precision and recall
which are metrics that are used widely
in the classification problems
an example data set used for this task
is called squad this data set contains
contexts questions and the answers that
are obtained from english wikipedia
articles
you can use question answering models to
automatically answer the questions asked
by your customers
you simply need a document containing
the information about your business
and query through that document with the
questions asked by your customers
for more information about the question
answering task check out the hugging
face course